la sécularisation nous a fait perdre
quelque chose qui existe et qui
s'appelait la charité chrétienne et qui
était la capacité à avoir un regard sur
les êtres qui allait sur leur dignité et
pas sur effectivement leur définition
physique sexuelle ensuite idéologique ou
politique et je pense que tout ça c'est
le trouble de notre époque qui ne sait
plus à quelle à quels repères ce ce
essayé de semer du fou ccc le pouvoir
politique est obligé oui car cette
charité à la place des gens qui vont au
delà et voyez que la la la la question
religieuse à avoir on parle bien de la
maire de paris comme notre dame notre
dame de paris
c'est parce que elle a quand même
maintenant une ambition ce sont des gens
qui veulent recomposer la société sur la
base de valeurs effectivement qui repose
sur le politiquement correct
oubliant que ce n'est pas au pouvoir
politique d'imposer les valeurs c'est la
société génère elle-même ses propres
comportements
alors je veux dire il n'y a rien de
choquant effectivement à alerter
l'opinion publique sur le fait que nos
comportements ne doivent pas être
discriminant mais il ya un côté
absolument caricaturale de la politique
de la mairie de paris mais je devrais
pas prendre le rôle de charles dans la
manière dont effectivement et elle est
devenue 7,7 mérite paris vraiment une
sorte de caisse de résonance de tout et
n'importe quoi